ein forschungsteam aus australien hat
die älteste farbe der welt entdeckt
hergestellt von lebewesen sie ist wohl
1,1 milliarden jahre alt und kommt aus
einer zeit in der es noch keine pflanzen
oder tiere gab und die analyse lüftet so
einige geheimnisse der konkrete grund
dafür
und welche farben und tatsächlich die
älteste aller zeiten ist klicks um
science-fiction bei uns gibt es jeden
tag 11 video wenn er nichts verpassen
wollt dann abonniert den kanal ok let's
go herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
diese entdeckung erklärt die evolution
neu und besser
jetzt wissen wir dass vor rund einer
milliarde jahren cyanobakterien die erde
bevölkerten und damit auch warum sich
genau deshalb damals noch keine
komplexeren lebewesen entwickeln konnten
mehrere hundert meter hatte man unter
dem westafrikanischen benin becken
gebuddelt um die jetzt entdeckten
farbstoffe aufschwung eigentlich war ein
großes unternehmen dort auf der suche
nach tonschichten die öl enthalten das
australische forschungsteam bekam das
gestein zur analyse und jürgen brocks
einer der beteiligten wissenschaftler
beschreibt die krasse überraschung die
dabei zutage kam ich hörte meine
mitarbeiterin schreien als die lösung
heraus kam die flüssigkeit in flächen
leuchtet das bringt das waren echte
uralte farbige moleküle die ältesten der
welt das uralte gestein aus der marinen
schiefer schicht hatte das
forschungsteam zu pulver gemahlen und
mit hilfe eines lösungsmittels die
pigmente extra jetzt sein fundort ist
das riesige sedimentbecken in westafrika
das wohl vor 11 milliarden jahren
entstanden das damals bedeckte ein ozean
die heutige sahara und in dem wimmelte
es nur so von winzigen bakterien die
analyse der gefundenen moleküle ergab
dann dass sie tatsächlich aus diesen
uralten cyanobakterien von damals
stammen die farbpigmente jedenfalls sind
in der konzentrierten form blutrot bis
purpur wenn sie verdünnt werden zeigen
sie sich leuchtend rosa damals
allerdings leuchteten sie wohl eher blau
grün doch im sediment hat nickel und
vanadium das ursprüngliche magnesium
atom z
tom ersetzt das führte dann zu den
rosafarbenen molekülen mit dem namen
purine dazu eine der beteiligten
forscherinnen nur wie nelly die
leuchtend rosa pigmente sind die
überreste von chlorophyll das von
cyanobakterien produziert wurde
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wissen also jetzt dass
die bakterien damals in der lage waren
photosynthese zu betreiben also den
prozess den auch heutige pflanzen
benutzen um durch sonnenlicht energie zu
gewinnen
der ehemals blau grüne farbton war exakt
abgestimmt und ziemlich clever von der
evolution denn damit konnten die
bakterien perfekt die passenden
wellenlängen aus dem sonnenlicht
absorbieren und die für die
photosynthese benötigte energie
aufnehmen diese cyanobakterien
bevölkerten zu dieser zeit wohl
massenweise die ozeane ihre existenz
erklärt nach annahme des forschungsteams
auch warum zu dieser zeit keine tiere
auf der erde lebten
denn diese wären durch die bakterien die
die dominierende nahrungsquelle in den
ozean bildeten niemals satt geworden
eine reichere energiequelle als die türe
bakterien waren dann erst die algen die
sich vor etwa 650 millionen jahren
extrem schnell ausbreiteten und die
cyanobakterien in den ozean verschwinden
ließen im vergleich zu den backend haben
diese nämlich ein bis zu 1000 mal
größeres volumen auch wenn viele alten
mikroskopisch klein sind ein krasser
energieschub also für die entwicklung
komplexer lebewesen dazu der forscher
jochum box wir haben also nicht nur als
pinkes zeug entdeckt sondern auch
geholfen zu erklären warum größere
lebewesen erst zu spät in der geschichte
auftaucht
wow hammer entdeckung und habe auch das
fast 4000 menschen unseren englischen
klicks um science-fiction kanal bereits
abonniert haben wir haben es uns sehr
auf klicks um zur aufgabe gemacht
wissenschaft für alle einfach zugänglich
zu machen und das jetzt auch auf
englisch euer feedback hilft uns dabei
den kanal weiter zu verbessern
danke schon mal dafür wenn er den kanal
noch nicht kennt klick gerne hier drauf
schaut vorbei und lasst uns ein abo da
empfiehlt uns gerne euren
englischsprachigen wissenschafts
freunden und freundinnen und danke für
eure unterstützung bis dann
bleibt dran